اذا العالم يعمل على اعطاء دفعه جديده
لمكافحه تغير المناخ وتداعياته التي تتولى
في عالم منقسم وقلق من ازمات اخرى اليوم
انطلق مؤتمر الامم المتحده حول المناخ
السابع والعشرون بمدينه شرم الشيخ وقال
الرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي على
تويتر ان مصر بصفتها الدوله المضيفه تسعى
للانتقال من مرحله التعهدات الى مرحله
التنفيذي باجراءات ملموسه على الارض من
جانبه شدد وزير الخارجيه المصري سامح شكري
على ان بلاده لن تدخيره جهدا لتحقيق اهداف
اتفاقيه باريس
ان الوقت قد حال للانتقال من المفاوضات
والتعهدات الى مرحله يحظى فيها التنفيذ
بالاولويه وفاه ذلك حتميه التعجيل بتنفيذ
ما ترىدين عليه في الاتفاقيه الايطاليه
لتغيير المناخ
وعززنا في اتفاق باريس وبرنامج العمل
الخاص به مع ضروره رفع مستوى الطموح لكل
الدول وفقا لقدراتها المتباينه
[موسيقى]
المتحده اليوم بان كل من السنوات الثمن
الاخيره ستكون اكثر حرارا من اي عام سابق
لعام 2015 المنظمه العالميه للارصاد
الجويه اشارات ايضا الى تسارع وتيره
ارتفاع مستوى مياه البحار وذوبان الانهار
الجليديه اضافه لتزايد موجات الحر
والكوارث التي تتسبب بها في كلمته
الافتتاحيه سلطه رئيس لجنه الامم المتحده
لعلماء المناخ الضوء على الضروره الملححه
لخفض انبعاثات غازات الاحتباس الحراري
واكد ان العالم ابقى على الهدف الرامي
لارتفاع حراره الارض دون درجه ونصف وكان
هذا العام شهد حتى الان سلسله من الظواهر
المناخيه المتطرفه التي فاقمها التغير
المناخي على سبيل المثال غمرت فيضانات
باكستان ثلث مساحه البلاد
قضى فيها ما لا يقل عن 1700 شخص اما في
شرق افريقيا فقد انحسر تساقط الامطار
لاربعه مواسم متتاليه ما فاقما ازمه
الجفاف هناك بدورها شهدت الصين اطول موجه
حر تسجل حتى الان وثاني اكثر فصول الصيف
جفافا
[موسيقى]